the associated press projects eric adams
as the winner of the democratic primary
in the race for new york city mayor and
that means
the former police captain will likely be
on the ballot in november and since
about two-thirds of
the city's eligible voters are
registered as democrats
adams is expected to win and be the next
mayor of new york if that happens
he will have a lot of work to do the
city is home to more than 8 million
people
and last year it saw one of the worst
coveted outbreaks in the nation
countless people and businesses are
still struggling financially
after more than a year of pandemic
shutdowns
adams currently serves as brooklyn
borough president and he joins us now
for an interview you will see first
on cbs this morning almost mayor adams
nice to meet you
nice to see you here thank you thank you
you know uh people always introduce me
as a former police captain
uh but the uniqueness of this moment uh
i call it esther
and fourteen god made me for such a time
like this i was arrested i was assaulted
by police officers
i didn't say what was me i said why not
me i became a police officer
i understand crime and i also understand
police abuse
and i know how we can turn around not
only new york but america we're in a
terrible place and we could turn this
country city around i want to dig into
those comments more but i want to get to
the big question at the top which is a
lot of people look
at your win or projected win and think
there are lessons here for the wider
democratic party and you yourself have
said you're the new face of the
democratic party
explain that because we have abandoned
uh our cities
uh what's happening in new york city is
taking place in chicago's south side
it's taking place
in california and atlanta you're seeing
gun violence and it's so pervasive
but it's not there's more than gun
violence if we don't educate we will
incarcerate
65 percent of black and brown children
in this city every year
never reach reaches a proficiency and
you're seeing the democratic party
basically they've thrown up their hands
and we're continuing to see the same
problems in our inner cities we need to
turn it around
so mayor governor cuomo has declared gun
violence in new york an emergency
situation there's been an uptick
the root cause it sounds like you're
saying is a lack of education and
support from the ground up
so true and my first question is what
took so long
and why is it taking us so long we're
watching these babies die
year after year after year and no one
seems to care and so we must have
intervention and prevention but why now
then with the uptick in gun violence we
saw it go down forever and it's not like
the education system suddenly got worse
well it's very interesting you may have
witnessed the national numbers or the
city-wide numbers but you still had the
crevices of gun
and gang violence in communities year
after year after year so the larger
numbers may decrease
but you still had the brownsvilles the
south south side of chicago's the
comptons the atlantas
we've ignored them because we were
prospering better economically but we
still had systemic poverty
in our cities so what exactly will cuomo
declaring the state of emergency do
as a mayor what would you do differently
or what can you do to address those
issues
well we have to really look into exactly
what the governor wants to do because
this is very new he announced it
yesterday
but it's going to allow the easiest
sex ability to finance and money
and we need to teach treat gun violence
as a public
health emergency every agency in the
city
in this country must be part of dealing
with gun violence because we deal with
the gun violence we're going to start
dealing with the
feeders of violence we've ignored that
for far too long
you know i've heard from some people in
law enforcement who say that gang
violence has gone up gun violence has
gone up because there is this idea that
they've heard about defunding the police
you have police departments who have
officers who no longer want to be on the
street after
you know so much turmoil over the last
couple years how do you fix that
as this crime is going up that's a great
question and and i say to my officers if
you don't want to be on the street
anymore then get off my streets
i don't want to hear someone say because
they don't like what government is doing
you're not going to protect my public
no i didn't like policing i didn't like
what the government was doing when i was
a police officer for 22 years but when i
put on that gun and shield i protected
the people of the city
i'm going to have the finest offices i
will have their backs but they're going
to have the backs of the people of the
city
and we're going to go to our lawmakers
and understand we're not going to make
lawyers that are going to be hurtful to
the public
and to our law enforcement officials
that's the problem that with
we're facing in this country do you feel
like that's what the democratic party is
also facing
an uphill battle well when you look at
the democratic party and you do an
analysis you find very few people have
ever been part of law enforcement
and we have demonized public protection
in this city
and country because we have too many
abusive officers
were allowed to stay in our agency but
at the same time we have ignored the
problems that
fed violence in our country and i said
we need to stop doing that
we're going new york is going to show
america how to run
cities because i know how to run the
city and i know how to lead
well then here's a question on running
the city you want to bring new york back
people are counting on you here in the
city of new york to bring new york back
the country needs new york to come back
it's the biggest city in the country
but bringing new york back does that
mean going back to
the unequal new york that is a hallmark
of the post bloomberg
boom how do you go back without
reinforcing
what was wrong in the first place well
those are the big mistakes that we made
um we have to end inequalities and those
inequalities are real
and we cannot continue to ignore that
they exist
and it really hurts it hurts folks like
you and i because listen let's be clear
we are sheltered from the real abuse
that our country is witnessing
and we there's a there's a permanent
group of people that are living in
systemic poverty you and i we go to the
restaurant we eat well we take our uber
but that's not the reality for america
in new york and so when we turn this
city around we're going to end those
inequalities and there's so many ways we
can do it we're dysfunctional
as a city and we're dysfunctional as a
country archbishop desmond tutu has this
quote
we spend a lifetime pulling people out
of the river no one goes upstream and
prevent them from falling in in the
first place
we're professional place of pulling
people out of the river
of poverty i'm going to take our city
upstream he's going to take our country
upstream
there's determination a lot of people
are counting on them
all right mr omos mayor congratulations
on your projected victory
uh and we'll see in november yes thank
you thank you